[Musique]
et merveilleux les visiteurs replongent
dans les décors de pièces de théâtre
datantes du 19e siècle forêt jardin
bâtiment d'époque ou encore scène de
bataille l'exposition les décors oubliés
au château de Monte-Cristo regroupe une
dizaine de maquettes rarement montrée au
grand public les 10 maquettes qui sont
présentées ici à Monte-Cristo il y en a
deux qui sont des décors de théâtre de
d'Alexandre Dumas il y a la tour de Neil
et la dame de Montsoreau ça aurait été
important pour Alexandre Dumas de savoir
que
bien après tous ces hommes qui ont
construit le théâtre et bien on leur
rend dommage parce que c'est un travail
minutieux de précision et ça fait partie
de notre patrimoine aujourd'hui ces
décors de théâtre sont magnifiques ils
sont peints à l'encre de Chine ou la vie
c'est très beau don Juan la poule aux
odeurs ou encore Jeanne d'Arc des pièces
de théâtre qui résonnent
sont précieusement gardés dans cette
exposition l'objectif les remettre en
lumière mais aussi rendre hommage au
savoir-faire de ses peintres et
décorateurs étaient construites sur une
échelle de 300e et le travail des
peintres par la suite une fois que la
maquette est acceptée par le directeur
du théâtre le travail des peintres était
de
reconstituer de confectionner les vrais
décors et donc il reportait c'était un
travail aux carreau donc il reportait
les trois centimètres pour 1 m sur de
grandes toiles tous ces décors viennent
d'une collection privée pour les admirer
vous avez jusqu'au 31 mai